us now former defense secretary former
c.i.a director
robert gates he's the author of the book
exercise of power
americans fail america failures
successes and a new path forward
in the post-cold war world mr secretary
thanks for being here
absolutely it's a pleasure to be with
you you know i read through uh some of
this book
and i'll tell you to be honest there are
some assessments here that are fairly
depressing about the world
and the u.s role in it but also
uplifting about the possibilities i want
to read one
sentence here how did our country go so
quickly from unique global power to a
country that is widely perceived as no
longer willing
to bear the costs or accept the
responsibility of global leadership
or even capable of governing itself
effectively
and that's a serious question to start
off this book
well and and it's a very real question
and and it really
has to do with uh probably 20 years of
war
and the exhaustion of the american
people with that
with two wars that stretched on for so
long
and what's worse wars that did not end
in
success except the original military
mission
given in both iraq and afghanistan was
quite successful
it was the non-military mission that the
military was given after those
initial successes that have proved so
frustrating
for americans and so costly and and
at the same time we have abandoned many
of the tools that we used
in the cold war with the soviet union
that we're going to need in our
competition with china in the years
ahead
there is a concern inside the pentagon
inside the intelligence community about
the pull out from afghanistan that it
it might leave a hole a vacuum you've
dealt with that as
defense secretary you've worked for six
presidents
afghanistan's a tough issue where do you
see that
there is a hunger politically to get
troops home
there is and you now have two presidents
in a row one republican one
democrat who've committed to getting all
of our forces out this year
i probably would have taken the same
position as
general austin or as secretary austin
and the joint chiefs of staff and
recommending uh
that we keep our small contingent there
but it was a very tough decision
and and the fact is even with our forces
there
uh the taliban are gaining ground every
single day
taking more territory and and so frankly
of all the possible endings
at this point in afghanistan a happy
ending is probably uh
is probably the least likely the one
thing that we have to do it seems to me
given the decisions that have been made
you know when
the soviets pulled their troops out
their
government the government they installed
of najibullah actually lasted for three
years
as long as soviet military and economic
assistance kept flowing
but once the soviet union collapsed the
najibullah government collapsed
so it's absolutely critical now that
this decision is made and we are pulling
our troops out
that we continue the flow of economic
and military assistance to to the afghan
government
otherwise i think they have little
prospect of success or of survival mr
secretary
we just had this piece by jennifer
griffin at the pentagon about the afghan
translators some 17 000 of them as u.s
troops leave
they fear that their lives are in
jeopardy what should we do about them
should we evacuate them
well i think we have an obligation to
them and we need to get them out
and frankly i think the way we've
treated a lot of the
interpreters that work with in
afghanistan
has been a disgrace we've been able to
get some out but not nearly enough
these people's lives are going to be at
risk
in afghanistan their lives and the lives
of their families they work for america
they risk their lives for our troops uh
we have an obligation to them and and
and if we fail to follow through on that
obligation then shame on us
uh you know in your last book uh duty
memoirs of the secretary of war uh you
wrote this about joe biden i think he
has been wrong on nearly every major
foreign policy and national security
issue over the past four decades
i asked you about that back in june of
2020 here's what you said
i stand by the statement that i wrote in
the book that
i obviously have very significant policy
differences with
with joe biden but i do think that he's
a
person of integrity and
a decent person and i think i'll just
leave it at that
do you sense that his judgment on
foreign policy is going to change now
that he's president
well what i found interesting is the is
the degree of continuity
in policy between the trump
administration and the biden
administration particularly when it
comes to
china and and russia uh
i think that the one change that i would
applaud
is is the recognition of the importance
uh in our in achieving our objectives of
uh taking advantage of our allies and
our alliances
uh and having them uh in concert with us
in
uh following policies dealing with china
as well as with
uh as well as with russia and vladimir
putin
but in those two very significant areas
it seems to me that there's a lot of
continuity with what went before
i think i think you're seeing a fair
amount of continuity
with respect to north korea they talk
about threading the needle between
what the obama administration did and
what the
trump administration did uh that
pretty much sounds like more of the same
to me right iran is definitely a
different story and how this is a
different story
i want to ask you about that in a second
but just uh back on um
the past time for then vice president
biden i just want to
straighten one thing out that has come
up we just celebrated i should celebrate
it we
marked the 10-year uh mark of the
bin laden raid uh that took down osama
bin laden remember that situation room
picture that is so famous you are in
there uh
and there is a book uh mark bowden on
the bin laden raid
the finish the killing of osama bin
laden and it says
in the end every one of the president's
top advisers except
biden was in favor of taking immediate
action
is that true it is
for uh for a good part of the debate
uh i i actually preferred i had no doubt
about the ability of the seals to carry
out the mission
but i preferred the use of a drone my my
worry
was given my responsibilities as
secretary of defense my worry was that
whether or not the
the raid was successful the pakistani
reaction would be so severe
that they would cut off our supply line
between karachi
and afghanistan and we would lose the
war in afghanistan almost overnight
but a couple of days before the raid i
was persuaded uh
that that the raid was the best
alternative and
was called the national security adviser
and told him that i that i supported
going forward with the raid biden was
not persuaded
that's my understanding
i said i was going to ask you about iran
there's a new defense intelligence
agency report
that says al-qaeda is during the past
year counter-terrorism pressure has
eliminated parts of al-qaeda's senior
leadership
overall ayman al-zawahiri remains in
hiding while a handful of iran-based
al-qaeda leaders oversee al qaeda's
network
inside iran this as obviously iran's
thumbing its nose at the u.s
enriching uranium to 60 percent still
funding terrorist operations in the
middle east
and the administration is trying to sit
down and renegotiate this deal
your thoughts on the juxtaposition there
of all of that
yeah i think we ought not have any
illusions about the iranian regime and
and uh and the people who are who are
running it and making the decisions one
of the points that i make in the book
exercise of power is that repeatedly
u.s administrations every u.s
administration has reached out and tried
to
improve relations with the iranian
government
and in every case even where you had the
iranian president
supporting such a move the ayatollah
put the kibosh on it and so we need to
understand that reality i i think that
my my concern is trying to go back to
the agreement
as it existed in 2015 half the time has
already gone
i was heartened for a while when they
were talking about lengthening and
strengthening in the agreement
i think i think we need an agreement
that says that the iranians will never
have a nuclear weapon we need
improved monitoring or verification
capabilities and we clearly need
something
that deals with their ballistic missile
programs and finally i would say
that if we're going to pursue these
negotiations the one thing we
must do differently than the obama
administration
is complete transparency and inclusion
of
the israelis and our gulf allies
and friends so that they know we're not
going to do a deal behind their back
that will be harmful to their security
interests
mr secretary we appreciate the time of
the book exercise of power
it's a great read about the past and the
future thanks a lot
thank you brett up next hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else